I know also you said something very
fascinating that although you love
associating with the people that you
work with in terms of the talent you
feel that it's better that you don't
know them as sort of the people in that
they are in the real lives right one of
the reasons why especially if you're
doing story and you're mostly working in
post what I have to work with and what I
can present to you is the image of a
person as it has come through the lens
onto a tape and has been presented to me
if I get to know you and I hang out with
you or we're friends or we get buddied
up there are a couple of things that can
go wrong one is I can start to get a
perception of you based on actually
interacting with you that may be
contrary to what's coming through the
lens where you're putting on a bit of a
show for me as you do sometimes when you
meet people and you want to be nice and
fun and impressive because that person
is important to the process or whatever
if you're trying to be on your best
behavior with me and then I see you
behaving strangely on camera it throws
it throws me off that I don't know how
to present you authentically and I start
thinking that I missing something or
there's something that should be there
that isn't then I just feel weird about
it so to keep that little bit of a wall
up there our field teams and field crews
and producers who work specifically with
the talent that if there's something
that I need I'll just drop them an email
and say can you ask them if they would
do this or that or the other or how do
they feel about this and that way I get
to be kind of the distant sometimes the
bad guy you know and they can in the
field has some someone to blame it on
and say listen you know they really want
this in post I know you don't want to do
it but they need it to be able to tell
this story I don't mind being put in
that position because it's in better
service of the story to have that person
think you know that I'm you know I'm the
bad guy who wants them to do X Y or Z
then for me to have an interaction with
them where they have my phone number or
they can drop me an email directly and
say listen I have a question about this
I did I will tell you I worked on a show
once where the show was airing while we
were still finishing the final episode
it was a very compressed schedule one of
the stars of that show I ran into them
at a grocery store and the guy basically
says to me hey you're making me look
like an and I basically told
them it's because I can't use footage of
you sleeping it's just you're constantly
grading on everyone I have to use what
it is that I have it's that thing where
they think that somehow how you process
that is how you're painting them when in
fact all you're really doing if you're a
competent story person is eliminating
the seams and trying to show that person
in the state that they were in when they
were being filmed you know and that
means warts and all you're going to be
who you were during the period of time
that you were being shot ie a heightened
version of yourself exactly well it's a
distillation it's like I talked about
like concentrated orange juice is if I
do if I only do three big things over
the course of a month and then you see
all of them happen in a half hour span
it looks like I'm really this person to
that person to it because that's what
that's what is happening that story
related the stuff where you're sleeping
or you're calling your mom just to say
hi and it has nothing to do with the
show that's not of use to me I can't use
it to tell a story so people just have
to get used to the idea that there is a
heightened reality version of themselves
it comes from that distillation and
that's where you get people who get very
upset because if they're naturally
antagonistic they're going to look
really antagonistic in the end all
reality TV can make you look like is
more of what you already are I can't
take a great person and make them look
like a terrible person I can't take a
terrible person and make him look at
your great person and that that's
paraphrasing JD Roth who it who had said
that originally is you can't make a
person more of something and I've always
remembered hearing that statement was
about almost ten years ago now that I he
was interviewed for something and it
really stuck with me
so when when that happened was that
around the time when you realize okay
it's probably that I did to remove
myself yeah I guess reasons I just think
that giving yourself a little bit of
distance between yourself and your
subject prevents them from feeling like
they have some sort of retroactive input
into you know some action that they took
it's not in my interest to ever make a
person look bad you should never look
like you know it I don't throw people
under the bus I don't create a situation
that didn't happen it's been known to
happen in reality shows where they paint
an inaccurate picture or they ask for
interview content where benign footage
suddenly looks like it's a really
damning indictment of you based on what
someone else is saying about you over
the footage I don't like to see those
things happen I think that anybody who
is nice enough to want to play ball and
be part of a reality show should be
treated with respect as a person who is
participating in your program but bad
things can't happen sure I just don't
I'm not going to actively seek you out
there's enough there's nothing that I
benefit from by making you look bad
you